ferngesteuerte hubschrauber und billard
dart oder tipp kick das sind nur einige
der disziplinen in denen diese männer in
einem spielwarenladen gegeneinander
antreten
wunderbar super ich hätte glaube ich
mehr söhne haben müssen als züchter wäre
vielleicht ein besseres spiel einige
stunden zuvor um acht uhr abends nach
ladenschluss ankunft der männer
neben einem schützenverein hat sich
heute auch eine feuerwehr gruppe
angemeldet insgesamt mehr als 50 mehr
verantwortlich für den abend ist heinz
lehmann
er war der erste der diese männer abende
veranstaltet hat und hat für das konzept
den deutschen innovationspreis des
bundestages gewonnen
es war so ist da mal jemand auf mich zu
und sagt ich möchte hier einmal
eingeschlossen seien älter her geht es
gibt nämlich machen
seit vier jahren kommen nun schon männer
zum spielen das geschäft ist fast die
ganze woche ausgebucht
er erlebte auf einmal glückliche männer
das geht ganz ganz schnell das heißt ich
komme aus mal rein haben keine ahnung
was eigentlich heute abend abläuft ja
und dann passiert einfach jetzt als bei
uns männern dass man so nicht
nachvollziehen kann
die regeln die männer werden in
vierergruppen aufgeteilt und fahren
kickern steuern um die wette jedermann
zahl 30 euro teilnahmegebühr
insgesamt geht es an elf stationen um
sieg oder niederlage
die uhr gefühle eines mannes ehrgeiz den
gegner zu schlagen aber zu gewinnen egal
weiß nicht was mir große jungs hier
können sie das alles erlaubt
männer und spielzeug das passt immer
mehr
die spielwarenbranche entdeckt zunehmend
den erwachsenen man als zielgruppe
besonders das internet ist dabei als
absatzmarkt gefragt die marke carrera
führt mittlerweile eine eigene rubrik
für männer
vor drei jahren hat die dänische firma
lego die plattform leben aufgebaut und
die modelleisenbahnen von märklin waren
sowieso schon immer eher etwas für
erwachsene
mittlerweile sind schon über 30 prozent
im internet einkaufen
das macht er den gesamten spiel waren
stationären handel zu schaffen und das
merken wir natürlich auch deswegen sehr
froh dass er natürlich diese zusätzliche
einnahme haben
das war abends im endeffekt hier mit
über 60 männer sind so wichtigen
verdammt schönen abend erleben dürfen
die spiele dauern rund vier stunden
zur stärkung werden wange brezeln und
bier verteilt
nein
kurz vor mitternacht steht dann der
sieger fest
ein rechtsanwalt er hat echte spieler
qualitäten bewiesen
sein preis ein matchbox auto als
erinnerung an einen gelungenen abend
stimmung machen damit sie das auch zu
würdigen wissen der abend ist schon gut
alles dabei richtig spaß
ich komme auf alle fälle wieder jens
lehmann ist zufrieden
seine männerabende sind in hannover
echte kult veranstaltungen und werden in
deutschland mittlerweile vielfach
probiert
mit